good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Monday hope everybody had a
blessed restorative and gorgeous weekend
speaking of gorgeous hey girly how you
darling how you doing swirly swirly swir
is doing good I did have a gorgeous
weekend thank you Dana joined me here
this weekend we had such a nice time we
created content we watched TV together
we really had a great time but I wanted
to share with the class that we did an
episode for patreon Jackson Dana extra
Anza just going down memory lane like
sharing such for those who might be new
here who's Dana oh Dana is my best
friend um from college so we've been
friends for like 13 years now she's one
of the redheads she's one of the
redheads we were talking on the episode
it's like you couldn't pick two more
different girls to be best friends but
like we're so similar in the things that
matter but optically we're so different
and that's Illustrated Dana and I did a
little Vlog because when she goes on
trips she packs everything in a JanSport
backpack even for her twoe honeymoon to
Hawaii so we did a bonus Vlog of her
showing how she packs in her JanSport
cuz of course she brought her jport here
like that could never be me where's your
skincare girl no it's literally the most
insane thing ever so not only for the
fourth episode this month did everybody
get a gorgeous podcast he also got like
a little bonus 10-minute Vlog yeah which
was really fun so I had a great weekend
with her and if you want to see what we
were up to check out patreon but lurd
how was your weekend well it was my
first weekend in my new place and it was
just amazing you know it was full of
natural light and happiness and food and
it was fabulous and I just love my new
home and just feeling so blessed so
excited to be here feeling so different
honestly I feel different she's a new
woman so are you into the change now
like I know last week you were having
cold feet you were yelling at everyone
and you were wishing I don't think that
I was you were wishing roll it back
we'll do it real roll it back I don't
think that I was yelling at anyone real
editor roll it back um no I'm not like
embracing change as a concept but I'm it
has its merits I'm pleased with this
specific change I'm not going to get a
bob now it's okay one step at a time one
day and what's so crazy is that it's
literally not even Halloween yet I know
but it's been the Halloween for like
four days except I do have to send words
of appreciation to everyone because I do
feel like I usually start seeing
Halloween costumes like 10 days before
Halloween and we only really started
seeing them this Friday which is
appropriate with Halloween being on a
Tuesday at first when I saw the First
costume I was like H it's starting but
then I was like girl no it's the weekend
before Halloween like this is kosher
same and I feel like we got to a place
like 2 years ago where people's costumes
were so insane they would just like get
dressed up have photo shoots and like
not go to a party or like go
trick-or-treating they would just get
dressed take a picture Instagram or to
do the Tik Tok or they got like four
different costumes four different photo
shoots like it got to a place where it
was insane and I feel like this year has
been very toned down down like people
put on normal costumes like went to a
party like of course every celebrity
goes to costum he goes party and now
Kendall Jenner had like an 818 party so
they go to a party get dressed to get
dressed in your house to not go anywhere
it's insane to do a photo shoot for
Instagram like get your priorities in
order I agree it was much more measured
and purposeful yeah and I didn't see any
costumes that were like so dumb you know
like Paris Hilton dressing as Britney
Spear's toxic like so cute perfect
perfect happy Halloween no like haly
Bieber She's Bambi or whatever that
kid's name is from the Flintstones she
was I I didn't see that yeah like a lot
of people were just doing costumes that
they sell at Halloween stores but
obviously like with the celebrity budget
what do you think is the reason for the
change there's by the way there's a
seismic shift there has been a shift
maybe like typically when Halloween is
being like stupid and extra large it
would have started like last weekend
with parties and stuff but maybe with
like everything going on in the world
like just people did less I don't know
uh I don't think so also like not me
getting dressed up last weekend too what
did you do last weekend o zic skeleton
true oh my God by no I've been insane
because it's like it's all work stuff
like last weekend was the Spritz event
so obviously I I had to go and and dress
up this weekend was actually Halloween
weekend so I dressed up on Saturday and
I'm literally dressing up twice tomorrow
in the morning and in the night oh my
god I didn't even realize you dressed up
for Halloween last weekend you're one of
become one of those people you're like
the only one of those people this year
too no I know but like I have to it's
for work like I will be dressing up
I'm not shaming you I'm
just I will be dressing up four times
and three of them are work commitments
okay first one was Spritz party tomorrow
morning is toast to ween tomorrow night
me and Ben are going to Heidi cl's
Halloween party and then the fourth time
which was this weekend was just regular
Halloween yeah what' you do I went to a
party that had like the most insane
theme I I can't it was technically
Dante's Inferno what the hell is that so
they sent out a mood board they sent out
a mood board and it's like nine circles
of hell so was a nine page mood board
for each circle of hell I guess based on
my outfit I was the violent
Circle I don't know whose party was this
I don't know I'm not going to slander it
was just honestly they sent out a mood
board that's like the thing now when you
do a theme you send out a mood board
it's
insane that's a lot yeah what about just
you know Under the Sea 80s famous
couples throughout history it always
comes back to famous couples throughout
history and by the way now that I've
like been to a lot of themed parties I
can tell you there would be no greater
theme than famous couples throughout
history like it's such an opportunity to
be creative to be like funny and I'd
like to have creative freedom while also
having parameters because I feel like
when it's a Halloween party it's like
you could be anything it does get kind
of hard when you could have so many
options but then when you Whittle it
down famous couple start at history it's
like okay there are so many yet it is
like limited and more specific famous
couples throughout history is the
greatest party theme period my next
birthday party by the way is famous
couples throughout history you say this
every year about your birthday do I like
kind of okay by the way I'm doing it
okay and what coule someone remind me
what couple would you be oh I'm not
telling you you no where's your mind
like going we could we could work
through some ideas Hest I think about
famous couples throughout history so
much but not what I would actually be
you could be Posh and beex yeah I would
I was thinking like I don't know like a
little bit more historical like
Victorian Albert no like a little bit
more current you know like um Elizabeth
and Phillip like kind of K and William
basic oh okay you're so cool I
am wait I have something to say you know
I've been on my rewatch journey of the
nanny yeah I finally finished it and me
and Ben were like what should we rewatch
I actually called you we were maybe
going to start Community I've been
wanting to start Gilmore Girls but I was
like you know what I have never never
done a full rewatch of Gossip Girl I
feel like every person has multiple
times I watched it when it aired and I
literally never saw it again same with
Ben so we we started it last night we're
on episode two and let me tell you I was
shocked why
shocked nobody talks about CU I remember
like you know the big moments I know
like Chuck and Blair OTP we're obsessed
with Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck just nobody
remember the first two episodes where he
legitimately like attempts to rape two
women Jackie I was Serena and Jenny like
violently I'm like me and Ben are
looking at each other we're like wait
this happened I don't know how he
becomes the hero I guess I'll find out
but like you're kidding me yeah he's
disgusting yeah that's very true nobody
talks about that yeah me and Ben were
shocked like it wasn't like he just
tried to kiss someone like he literally
was being insane yeah and the roof with
Jenny the roof yeah the RO bad yeah
that's bad nobody talks about that like
and I look forward to seeing how they
you know bury that yeah because to me
it's
shocking yeah that's a plot hole for
sure a big plot hole and another element
of the show it's just like a little
difficult for me to get around like is
the cringe like it's so like hey upper e
ciders regular people eat brunch the
upper e ciders have brunch like it's so
cringe yeah yeah I'm sure it gets better
cuz like literally was the pilot and
then the second episode like I'll give
it some time but me and Ben were like I
just don't remember this and I bet when
I was a teenager cuz Gossip Girl was my
life like I thought I was a character I
bet I thought it was so cool it's
literally like loserville stop well I
rewatched it recently I think I only I
don't even know if I got through the
whole first season so that like tells
you that I obviously wasn't like
desperate to keep watching also not them
literally telling us who Gossip Girl is
in the first episode yeah but don't you
feel like that was a coincidence maybe I
feel like they didn't know who Gossip
Girl was going to be until the finale
but if you watch that first episode it's
abundantly but then also like throughout
the seasons it doesn't make sense that
Dan is go I'm pretty sure he like outed
that Jenny lost her virginity yeah yeah
like so I don't think they knew that
spoiler alert danam was going to be
Gossip Girl until the end when they were
trying to make a decision because in the
books it's never revealed I always
thought it should have been revealed
some wannabe yeah of course no no but in
the first episode the episode ends with
like the Gossip Girl monologue Christen
Bell's voice and she goes and who am I
literally cut to Dan sitting at his
computer
oh he's on the Gossip Girl website yeah
because it looked like he was just
reading Gossip Girl it could have been a
coincidence it's it can't like it
literally can't well good for them if
they really plotted that out all along
oh and another thought it's interesting
just how like your thoughts change as
you grow up like when I remember growing
up every time they would like show the
humph I'm like please stop showing me
these people let me tell you they had
such a nice life like their family was
full of love Rufus was such a good dad
he was a single dad Jenny and Dan were
so close like what siblings like are
that close in high school what a lovely
Shalom Bay they had like for real then
but their issue was that they went to
that school that then made them like
they got corrupted yeah they got
corrupted and then like Rufus is like
living large with
Lily yeah that's true that's true and
Dan just becomes like a Manore yeah yeah
yeah it's just interesting no but it is
cute how like throughout in the
beginning like you know Serena goes to
the humph and like she experiences like
what real family is and same with Blair
when she goes to that Diner in Brooklyn
with them that one time I think it was
like Christmas or something you'll get
there I just want to like say justice
for the Humphries W they were good heish
down to earth salt of the earth people
they started that way yeah just wait
till Jenny's like but then that upper
side corruption yeah no it was the upper
side corruption but also the show is
stumb Jenny was like just too desperate
like you'll get there oh by the way that
that comes through in episode one like
so it's but she's so young and there was
just so much Temptation that upper side
lifestyle yeah but no like Brooklyn was
where it's at like Brooklyn was where
like the good family values were
yes oh my God it's so it's actually very
interesting to watch okay well keep us
posted on your thoughts I started
lessons in chemistry which is the Apple
TV show that's based on the book lessons
in chemistry we read it for the redheads
last year and we loved it and the show
is so good really yeah in the beginning
give it a second cuz at first I was like
this is cringe um but then it just it's
beautiful I think you'll like it even if
you didn't read the book but you're
going to be really shocked by what the
story is I don't even know if they
changed it no no but like the watching
the show is L shocking cuz I know what's
going to happen yeah right if you don't
know what's going to happen I I read the
book I know but I feel like you don't
know which specific thing I'm talking
about is it about her man yeah duh when
you're watching the show like you just
think that's the last thing that's going
to happen when I was reading the book I
was like are you [__] kidding me and
honestly I was like over the book when
that happened I'm like you're not
kidding me right so I'm on episode 4 but
now I have no time for TV because I'm
reading the next redheads book The Dead
Romantics I'm 40% and it's really cute I
actually think you might like it because
it's about a writer girl who writes smut
it's about Carol radwell who writes smut
obsessed and she references like all the
Grits you know
um It Happened One Summer yeah like red
white and royal blue reference like they
reference other authors cuz it's like
about the publishing World she's a ghost
writer for like a big smut writer oh
it's like younger yeah uh no because
it's also about ghosts but it's oh it's
our it's our Halloween pick so that's
why oh that's funny I can't do books
that are not based in reality like the
measure I didn't like I'm reading fourth
Wing now I'm having such a hard time I
don't get it I know I don't get it you
have to have patience do you notice
anything different about me cuz we need
to talk about you're wearing a color
that you never
wear okay you probably can't see me hold
on oh blue jeans and my favorite shoes I
can't see your jeans but you also never
wear that color sweater no I don't um
it's from Stitch fix I'm like kind of
obsessed with Stitch fix um but I'm
wearing jeans today yeah let's talk
about it tell me how you feel yeah
interview me about the jeans you're
wearing jeans today is this your first
time wearing blue jeans or first time in
recent memory this might be my first
time ever wearing blue jeans definitely
blue jeans and definitely jeans that
aren't skinny and where did you purchase
these jeans well when went on my whole
tie raid after the NFL game about not
having jeans I was reached out to by
many a company and these are Old Navy
what size are they kid that's a good
question I actually don't know they fit
like a dream what is the
cut I have no idea like they're not
skinny no but they like they're tapered
straight straight leg straight leg
straight leg yes I like a straight leg I
like a straight leg too and how do you
feel in these jeans I do feel good but
like does society talk about like how
many more wedgies you get when you're
wearing jeans like I actually have to
stick my hand down my pants and rip my
undies from my butt like you're like
Leonardo cio's girlfriend oh did she
pick her wedgie she stck her hand down
his pants it's a story today oh yeah
actually I did see that I didn't even
know he had a new girlfriend yeah um
also we need to talk about one thing um
so like not to make everything about me
but over the weekend I sliced my finger
open while being like so fat I was so
hungry I like needed this bagel I was
being so reckless and of course like it
was traumatic and I'm not looking for
sympathy but I'm wearing a
Band-Aid and we need to talk about how
wearing a
Band-Aid I don't think there's anything
uglier than a
Band-Aid yeah well they do make you know
fun Ones for kids like you but okay I'm
wearing like a beige Band-Aid like it's
just like I feel disgusting I feel like
juny Cortez not just that it's ugly but
that's really unsanitary it just like
gets wet and then dry and it just
carries all these things around with it
no it's sick it is pretty sick refu yeah
I just feel like not enough people talk
about how like wearing a Band-Aid like
ruins your whole look you could be going
to the mechala like in the most the
finest threads and like if you're
wearing a Band-Aid like go leave
speaking of um injury sort of I saw
something this morning I'm wondering if
you saw it the hockey player thing I did
I literally just saw it um on X and I
hadn't seen it anywhere like I haven't
even seen on Instagram but like there
was a hockey game and one player like
kicked another player in the throat but
you know they wear skates so he sliced
his throat and he died on the ice like
he killed it happen in Canada oh I don't
know but he killed him yeah I I don't
know if he kicked him I I didn't see
that I saw that it was like a freak
thing I like but how do you
freakishly get your foot in someone's
throat I can't believe it's not a bigger
story cuz I saw it on Tik Tok and people
were like rip rip I'm like what yeah
people are saying it's like a freak
thing but like other people are saying
like this is manslaughter no it's the
saddest thing ever like he was literally
dead on the ice like that whole Arena
full of people yeah no he like went down
in the like blood pool and then he later
died from the injury no I saw it too I'm
so glad you brought that up I was shook
and I couldn't believe more people
weren't talking about it but I think
it's because it's not an American League
I'm pretty sure it was like Canadian not
that it doesn't not that it's not
important because it happened in Canada
I'm just saying we're America it just
happened and like it'll it'll cycle
through the news and because it's
jarring to see I know it's traumatizing
for the people who are
there he died he was murdered playing a
game no it's
insane it's insane insane I saw it too I
don't know what's going to happen me
neither like do they press charges it
does kind of beg the question like why
are we skating around on like knives
like I know that's how you skate but
like maybe we should do it in a roller
rank no but like you're not meant to
lift your leg and like you're a
professional athlete like you know that
you you have control of your leg Yeah
yeah no it's really
nuts so that was shocking to see this
morning yeah really sad amongst other
things the news is just it's hard to
pick stories cuz I confronted with like
you know I'm on Daily Mail homepage they
have everything they have world news
they have celeb news and
like supposed to do the show a really
sad story I'm sure we're going to talk
about is Matthew Perry mhm I have so
many thoughts okay yeah that's our first
story if you want to get into it uh is
there anything else you want to get into
well you didn't ask me about my beef
stew no I didn't I I I own that I can
own my own [__] I did not ask you about
your beef stew tell all it was really
good I liked it because it was a one pot
dish cuz wait you liked it because uh I
like it cool it was a one pot dish so
pretty easy pretty easy cleanup it's
like you just have to assemble it and
then leave it kind of like a chili but
like way less chopping and actually a
lot less Manpower than a chili okay and
it was super Hardy I couldn't get enough
we finished it there was not a scrap
left I wish I made more and I said this
on the patreon but I wish wish that I
added more vegetables so that I had like
more Meal m it like wasn't enough meal
even though it was beef carrots potatoes
onions stew beef beans tomatoes potatoes
that sounds nice I'm so happy it's
totally like stew season get your big
carway Dutch oven whatever you got like
Le cruset get it out like and leave it
on the counter cuz it's the season and
I'm so excited about it actually I've
been making so much content in my new
house like it just I'm going to become
like a new like a like an aesthetic
content girly it's just so easy in my
new home like with all the natural light
oh what's your beat like what kind of
content are we going can we expect to
see like food fashion lifestyle I I
think the content you can expect to see
hopefully is sponsored like if I'm being
honest no it is that season like Q4 I'm
booked and busy make sure to like And
subscribe you know support your girl for
sure like And subscribe to me too yeah
no as yeah like me first and then Jack
oh you think well yeah because I I said
it first I feel like it depends what
kind of content you're looking to serve
why don't you make the case for yours if
you're a human being you'll like my
content that's kind of a low bar these
days cuz not a lot of people are it's so
true by the way not me like literally
losing or like 10 12 13 like 15,000
followers in the last couple of days oh
really yeah do you think I give a [__]
bye they weren't human beings right no
like if you are bothered by like me
speaking on anti-Semitism like please
I'm literally begging you go go go to
sleep she only wants to human beings you
guys oh also speaking of go to sleep and
we actually have really good stories
today that Vanity Fair article that we
talked about last week is you know this
big expose was coming out Vanity Fair
about Bravo it dropped this morning I
did read about 75% of it it's really
long it's really long and they had a
word count to hit you know there's
advertisers I had to do the reader viiew
because they wouldn't let me read the
article without becoming like a
subscriber of Vanity Fair really mine
was totally fine cuz if they put their
popup up and then I was like no go back
to V fair and bring me back to the
homepage I couldn't stay on the article
so I hit reader viiew really fast fast
so I got the read ofview but I don't get
all the pictures oh I saw the pictures
and they there were a couple Housewives
who are part of it a bunch of remained
Anonymous but a bunch they had a whole
photo shoot like I didn't get to see cuz
I was on reader viiew oh it was actually
really beautiful photography Justice for
me
jfu so we'll get into that I think we
could get into the stories now without
further here are the fast five stories
that you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by drizzly the go-to app
for drink delivery drizzly is the most
convenient way to get beer Wine and
Spirits delivered to your doorstep right
when you want it drizzly tailored
experience lets you find the perfect
drink for the occasion no matter what it
is you'll save time by shopping a huge
selection of drinks from wherever you
are you'll also save money by comparing
prices on drinks across multiple stores
so it's great for gifting whether you
are going to someone's house for a
dinner party it's holiday party season
you know you told your husband to go
pick up the the gift he obviously forgot
to do it drizzly can save the day while
you're getting ready order it it'll be
there before you leave you can also
schedule deliveries so if you're going
to a party in the future you know your
husband's probably going to forget you
could just schedule it have it sent to
your door their door it's perfect for
the holiday season they've got the
planned and last minute gifter covered
with the option to schedule ahead ship
and deliver gifts on demand drizzly is a
fabulous app to also discover new
beverages if you're just like browsing
looking for something new in a lot of
States you can get sprit Society on
drizzly which is why it's a favorite
over here at the toast so download the
drizzly app or go to drizly.com that's
Dr r i z
l.com use code toast to receive $5 off
or a $0 delivery fee off your next order
you must be 21 or older it's not valid
in all states codes cannot be combined
with any other offers not valid at all
retailers code expires November 10th
2023 11:59 p.m. eastern time again so
download the drizzly app or go to
drizly.com that's d r i l y.com and use
code toast today's episode is also
brought to you by Legacy box friends and
family gathering for the holidays is is
always going to bring up memories of
holidays past moments you wish you could
go back and relive and with Legacy box
you can reliving moments of holidays
past is easy with Legacy box trusted by
over a million families including ours
Legacy box is simple affordable and safe
Legacy box is also the brand I feel like
I get the most DMS about being like what
was that company cuz you guys aren't
listening well listen up cuz now it's
holiday season and this is really like
the best gift if you're going to be
spending time with your family over the
holidays do the Legacy box now and share
it with them all for the holidays it's
literally the best gift and starting now
our listeners get early access to their
best sale of the year which can digitize
your tapes for as low as $9 a tape so
Legacy box is a company that's going to
digitize all of your home memories we
grew up in the VHS era we had so many
vhs's just sitting in a basement which
is so dangerous because the elements you
know a flood the air it can melt a bunch
of different things you should take care
of it now and the process is really easy
send in your legacy box filled with old
VHS tapes cam camcorder tapes and
pictures and their team will
professionally digitize everything by
hand in the USA you'll get it back on
the cloud or a thumb drive along with
the originals they digitize over 15
types of analog media like VHS super 8mm
film reels photo negatives they have got
you covered so think of all the
Christmas mornings you recorded relive
those memories with your family this
holiday season on the big screen relive
the most important memories and take
advantage of Legacy Box's best sale of
the year when you visit legacybox.com
toast you'll get early access to the
Black Friday sale and start digitizing
your memories for as low as $9 of tape
that's over $60 60% excuse me off
legacybox.com toast today's episode of
is also brought to you by kit
gamechanging that's what Kit's biggest
fans say about their time-saving beauty
Essentials for Hair Skin and Body so are
you ready to change the beauty game
whatever your budget whatever your skin
or hair type kit believes that you
deserve little indulgences at affordable
prices morning noon and night so maybe
you've seen their satin pillowcases the
caps and eye masks which are great for
your hair and skin while you sleep or
maybe you've seen their heatless satin
curling rollers where uh people are
saying goodbye to heat damage whatever
you're looking for Kit has got it I've
discovered so many like new Beauty
things from kit I now wear a silk eye
mask and a silk pillowcase because my
hair used to wake up like I could get a
full I could get the best blowout Chris
Appleton could do my hair before I went
to sleep and if I don't use my kit
products when I wake up it's completely
gone saves me so much time in the
morning I can wake up a lot later thank
God for that um they also have uh
shampoo and conditioner bars which is a
part of bottle-free Beauty Plus right
now for a limited time you can live the
Barbie dream life with their Barbie by
kit collection featuring Kit's
best-selling satin pillowcase in iconic
Barbie pink so right now kit is offering
you 30% off your entire order at my
kit.com toast that's right 30% off
anything and everything at my kit kit
t.com toast one more time that's my
kit.com toast for 30% off your order
take care of your hair and skin whatever
you need I love their claw Clips
whatever you need just go to the website
and you will find what you're looking
for Hair Skin otherwise it's a great
company founded by women they have a
cult like following and they are
creating gamechanging Essentials that
beauty enthusiasts swear by like the
satin pillowcases and time-saving towels
they know hair care doesn't stop in the
shower thank you thank you Claude you're
welcome okay our first story is the big
news from this weekend which was that
Matthew Perry sadly passed away his
autopsy is complete with toxicology
results pending says the Med medical
examiner so the investigation into
Matthew Perry's death continues the LA
County Medical Examiner office confirmed
to page six on Sunday that an autopsy
was completed for the late friends Alum
however the doctor has ordered more
testing including toxicology all of
these results remain pending and his
cause of death has been deferred for the
time being uh Matthew Perry died on
Saturday at the age of 54 with his
assistant finding him unresponsive in
his La H's hot tub after an apparent
drowning TMZ reported at the time that
there was no signs of Foul Play TMZ also
claimed that although illicit drugs were
not found on site there were multiple
prescriptions on the premises including
anti-depressants anti-anxiety drugs and
a COPD strug the actor had spoken
candidly about his alcohol and opioid
struggles over the years detailing his
sobriety journey in his Memoir last year
friends l and the big terrible
thing okay this was you know I feel like
we report on celebrity deaths a lot and
not all of them like really like stop
you in your tracks I feel like because
he was on friends so many people feel so
connected him it's so many people's like
Comfort show it's so many people's show
that they watch with their families they
just like have really positive memories
from it and his character is like the
big funny man and I just saw it and I
was so upset and so sad especially
because he's been so open about his
battle with addiction and I think based
on you know a lot of the details that
have come out like it's clear that he
lost his battle with addiction and so I
think anybody who struggles with
addiction feels this even harder because
not only did he struggle publicly he
also recovered publicly and he started a
house for men who um are struggling with
addiction he wrote about it in his book
how he does so much work in the you know
recovery community and so for somebody I
think he just means a lot to a lot of
people whether it's friends or whether
it's you know because he's kind of a
spokesperson for addiction that it just
hit people so hard myself included like
I'm so sad like really really sad and I
had been wanting to read his book and
now I think I'm definitely going to read
it I think there's a lot of things that
are being pulled from it you know I've
seen like a bunch of Tik toks and stuff
and one of the things he said was like
you know when my time comes I I know
that everyone will remember me from
friends and that's great that I made
this thing that people love and could
laugh at and be entertained by but I
really hope I'll be remembered for like
the work that I did in in the addiction
world and so I don't know it's just it's
so like Eerie to hear someone talk about
their own death this was like literally
two years ago probably when he wrote it
uh it's just terrible it's so sad this
is just one that really hit you right
right in the gut yeah really shocking so
many people are like speaking out
tributes but it's like it's so sad when
someone passes before their time yeah
and I think people are so obsessed with
like the interpersonal relationships of
all the friends and their way waiting
for like everyone to speak I think a lot
of people are really waiting for
Jennifer Anderson to speak cuz like the
big bombshell from his book was like he
has and always will be like in love with
Jennifer Aniston like she was it for him
but there's no he doesn't have any bad
blood with any of the Friends cast memb
today oh so everyone like will speak in
their own time but it's like they're
probably grieving much more than the
fans like to then also have to put out a
statement that's going to be like you
know picked apart and you want like it's
just too much like take your time yeah
no but they are all good yeah good good
there was a time where like David
trimmer like was being but he got he he
reeled it in yeah dvo dvo extraordinaire
yeah also you're not being pulled over
you guys there's like a a cop car right
behind me like they don't even care that
I'm podcasting no they don't respect the
toast clearly they don't respect the
toast they don't respect me okay it's
gone um this was just so upsetting and
it's so interesting how so many people
are having like such personal reactions
to this because he just like was that
guy especially like I think if this
happened you know with any of the cast
members of friends it's just that type
of show but Chandler specifically like
was the comedic relief of the show he's
like this big teddy bear and it's just
really sad like really really really sad
yeah and like really kind of creepy like
weird like these things just that happen
are so weird his last Instagram post is
him in his jacuzzi and they believe the
jacuzzi is where he was found yes oh wow
creepy yeah very well hopefully we'll
have like more answer soon as to what
happened um with the toxicology report
but and not to go on like my Dennis's
funeral sort of Rampage again but did
you see the paparazzi footage of like
his parents showing up to his house no
it's just [__] horrible a lot of
people don't know that Matthew Perry's
stepdad is that guy Keith marrison who
hosts day line like the classic guy oh I
didn't know that and they were very very
close um and so he's at the house and
his Matthew Perry's parents are pulling
up and there's 55 photographers and
they're just trying to get out of their
car it's and it's just dead silent
nobody's saying anything it's just so
weird that is so weird I know like the
element of the media and Paparazzi
culture when it comes to death the fact
that nothing changes like from just
regular you know celebrity getting gas
there's no sort of decorum there's no
it's really insane to me and that's why
I'm always going off about Dennis's
funeral yes it always comes back to
Dennis's funeral it does cuz the exact
like two grieving parents let them get
out of their [__] car yeah and you
know those like Hollywood Hills streets
small and windy like there's nowhere for
them to go the winding Hollywood roads
literally give me goosebumps and chills
yeah so I'm sure we'll be talking about
him all week I hope you do read his book
and maybe share definitely am his wisdom
with the class he was just like this
really like heish guy I had watched his
60- Minutes special no what's 60 Minutes
like Diane Sawyer type of thing um to
promote his book right I remember we
were talking about him all the time this
time last year and I was was really
moved by it but I also felt like I um
everything that was in the book was in
the interview cuz it was like a long
thing yeah um but so many quotes are now
being pulled and I'm just seeing like
things on social media like he talked
extensively about dating Julia Roberts
he like could not believe that he dated
Julia Roberts cuz she was like the
biggest movie star and he was yeah a big
TV star but TV back in the day like TV
was gross like nobody like TV was like
lower
thanan pedestrian and he he said I just
could not believe every time she called
me well actually he said every time she
would send me a fax that's how they
communicated I thought it was going to
be her breaking up with me and I got to
the point where I was so insecure like I
actually broke up with her because I
just couldn't stand being in a
relationship waiting for that person to
break up with me that's that's like so
crazy the look of confusion on Julia
Robert's face when I broke up with her
was something I'll never forget that's
what he
said wow yeah I'm so I'm definitely
going to read his book once I get
through this fourth Wing that I'm hating
um are you through fourth Wing like 15
oh 30 yeah I know I know I'm going to
stick with it DED you got to dedicate
time like you got to get through big
chunk maybe I'll see if my book club
wants to do it I keep bringing up
Memoirs and like everybody's so against
it your book club should do fourth wi no
I meant Matthew Perry oh because they
all love friends in my book club well I
don't want to tease anything but Dana
and I were she has the next pick for
redheads mhm and she like didn't know
what to pick and I don't want to like
spoil it but I think don't no but I
think people will be excited okay go
take a guess Britney I think so yeah you
gotta it's st's choice but she was like
loving the choice cuz she was like I
probably wouldn't read it if it not for
redheads there's nothing else that she
was like dying to pick and we like to
pick a book that's like kind of Buzzy
because then more people are introduced
to the redheads yeah of course Buzzy is
good yeah like fourth Wing people love
that yeah yeah know you got to be on
Trend and also I do think Britney's book
is good yeah and I think would be make
for a really good episode so I think
we're gonna do it I love that and that's
just a little behind the scenes sneak
peak so you're saying the redheads are
trying to find the woman in me is that
you're say all we need is
time I can't sing it without singing it
like you and in your special all I need
is time don't you sing it like that that
is my yeah while I'm in between that's
literally the best song I'm not not a
girl I'm not a girl don't tell me what
to
believe not yet a woman I'm just trying
to find the woman in
me it's such a beautiful song and like
not it being from Crossroads like but
whenever I see the title The Woman in me
I always sing of the song and it brings
out the woman in me no it only brings me
to Crossroads it feels like the first
time it feels like the very first time
feels like an episode of Glee today it's
oh have you been here no but that's such
a Glee song it reminds me of Pitch
Perfect same thing what song is
that feels like the first time
right if I sear woman in Me lyrics it's
going to be know it's like it's such a
Mr Shoe song No to me it's
who sings it feels like the first time
ohe who Foreigner The Foreigner I don't
even know who that is Foreigner oh so
it's just like Journey where they have
like one song Mr Shoe Mr but I do want
to know Jackie I don't think journey I
think Journey has more than one song no
no one song that we know by the you
can't tell me that Journey Bono and you
two and B wait is Journey
bonjovi no yeah yeah B
Journey wait what band is bonjovi or is
he just
bonjovi he's just bonjovi and Bono is
just Bono Bono's you
too classic yeah and who's Journey
Journey's like kind of freaky Journey B
no yeah you're telling me Journey's like
a bunch of people you don't know Steve
Perry Oh okay and so Bon Joi is the name
of the band but it's lead song lead
singer is John
bonjovi yeah wait hold on hold on hold
on a minute I'm looking up Journey band
and we have the vocalist Lee guitar bass
guitar Randy
Jackson it's just a common name there's
no way no it's a picture wait
wait cladia wait wait journey I don't
believe
you no that's not him I'm looking at a
picture of the band and it's five white
guys it's it's not Randy Jackson oh then
on mine the legend Claudia on mine it is
Randy Jackson what do you mean on yours
what website are you on just on Google
like when you go down to
members search Journey band I went to
Journey band Google images and it's five
old white men with long hair okay now go
to Google page Journey band and scroll
like right above songs it says members
and it's a picture of Randy Jackson no
way yes you're right it does say that
Jackie former member of Journey
Santana Carlos he s it just says Santana
is that Carlos
Santana no Santana's a band okay I'll
I'm honestly confused wait Journey's
American rock band form by the former
members of
Santana steeve Miller Band and isn't
Santana don't they have that song
santoria or is that Santa no that's
that's that's not Santana I ain't got no
santoria I ain't got I don't think
that's Santana that's like one of Ben's
favorite songs okay but Carlos Santana
is the guitarist for Santana and Carlos
Santana um is a founding member of the
toast as well because if you remember if
if you know you know if you know you
know but like I'm so in a place of of
these bands I have no idea what I'm
talking about that's what I'm saying so
Bon Joi the point I was trying to make
John Living on a Prayer that's it it's
my life so
emo yeah that's a good
song The Day The M that's a good song I
think it'll do well I think it'll do
well too I'm happy for them are you
ready for our next story yeah that was I
don't even know how to I don't know how
to go back to where we came from just go
actually I do the woman in
me yes our next story vany Fair Bravo X
expose dropped called inside the real
house IES Reckoning that's rocking Bravo
amid disturbing allegations Bethany
Frankle called for a union and a whole
lot of drinking reality TV's most
popular stars are facing their demons so
Vanity Fair has been working on this for
a few months we shared they sat down
with former Housewives Bethany Frankle
Leah mcweeny lended her voice to the
interviews who else did you hear from
ebony K Williams yes hers and Leah both
of their stories it's interesting
because they were I think they were and
I didn't finish the whole article
because it was so
Long's part so it sounds like so much of
the toxicity they're talking about is
honestly confined to The Real Housewives
of New York interesting well also maybe
that's like the people who spoke out
Bethany Leah ebony that's true but also
most of what they're talking about that
I've read so far is the drinking problem
which we've talked about so often on the
show and that also was the biggest
factor for real houswives of New York
like it was so but also the biggest
factor for real houswives of New York CU
think about the the time and this is
Ebony's his is ebony's uh experience
that she's talking about is literally
was the drinking and then the final
season was the first time they had a
black cast member right yeah and so much
went on and I remember hearing stuff
like investigations were being whatever
and we never got like conclusive
anything as to what actually happened
and they're talking about it and like
Ebony's experience and um it's really
centered a lot around Ramona like
apparently she used the n-word like
colloquially and Ramona's respond like
so many of like the people talked about
in this article like NBC Executives Andy
Cohen um Bravo people were reached out
to for comment and none of them
responded literally Ramona is answering
every single PRP I saw that charge and
she said never did she say that she said
never and and then it comes back again
they have um so when they hired ebony
they also hired like a bunch of uh
female black producers and when a new
producer comes on like they usually get
introduced to everyone it's made clear
what exactly this person is going to be
doing and so the castmates will then
respect the person but all like when
they brought on a bunch of black
producers they like didn't introduce
them to anyone so they would like try
the new producers would try and like
text Ramona and Luan and Sonia and not
one of them would literally respond or
acknowledge they didn't know who these
people were it was never made clear and
then um Ramona was like basically trying
to say like when she grew up she was um
referred to as a shika by some of her
Jewish friends and she says to this new
Black producer
you know that's like someone calling you
oh and Ramona denies that it happened
but uh there are a bunch of people who
corroborate that it did happen so that
that is what started this whole
investigation into Ramona and then roony
Legacy and they never were they never
told anyone what happened the uh
investigation was inconclusive Ebony
Ebony was ebony asked like ebony went to
HR was like what the [__] like and they
were like sorry the report was
inconclusive so a lot of I think the
downfall of or kind of the basis of this
article is really about like the last
year last couple of years of roony
because that's Leah too Leah comes on
she's 10 years sober she downplays it
because she's told like it won't be very
interesting and she's she told a
producer during like her interviews and
auditions that she was like kind of like
drinking again and they like loved that
yeah but she also said that like because
she didn't want them to know that she
had relapsed is what I read like yes cuz
then it would that would be her
storyline like that she relaps as
opposed to her um narrative was like she
in and out of drinking which people do
yes which people do and she was very
convincing when she said that I was like
okay I guess can do that yeah also
what's something I learned from this
article that I found really interesting
is this this concept of hot sheets so
like after every day of production they
like put into writing everything that
happened and it's very like not PC it's
stuff that's never supposed to see you
know the public is never supposed to see
and they send it to a bunch of
Executives including Andy and Andy sends
notes and they actually have like a lot
of transcripts of those hot cheets and
Andy's notes in return how do they that
there must be there are a bunch of
people who spoke off the record from
production companies from maybe Bravo
who have those emails they're not
they're not confidential they're not
classified I haven't seen anything I
mean the whole thing is pretty damning
for Bravo but not totally more so for
reality TV in general I don't think
there's anything that's Bravo
specifically unexpected like that's what
you know you would expect from you watch
the show it's clear yeah but I have do
you see any comments from Andy that like
you think he really needs to answer for
um I mean like yeah but Bravo's not like
this like I feel like crazy stuff
happens on Bravo all the time yeah and
they just kind of like move on you know
yeah and because there's so many people
in production companies there's no one
person that's going to be held
accountable it would be Andy but I think
he's like distanced himself enough he
now his line is like I don't do I'm not
their boss anymore I'm not in charge so
there's no one to be like hey can you
fix the culture around here it's true
but I also think it's probably not a
Bravo specific cultural thing like it's
a reality TV type of thing and that's
more so what Bethany is trying to say
with her Union yeah no and it's an issue
because it's the E reality TV is like
the exploitation of people's personal
lives and you want it to be interesting
so you have to dial up the crazy but
then your personal life is affected like
it's a catch 22 yeah and I also think
that when I was reading a lot of the
stuff especially about drinking I don't
really see that as like a
Bravo cultural thing I just see that as
like a thing in the culture like getting
so blacked out and peeing your pants and
not remembering and waking up in a pool
of your own like fluids that's just like
2023 things that's like not just a Bravo
thing I totally agree it's a bachelor
thing too it's a Vanderpump Rules it's
it's also a reality TV thing because
that's an easy way to be more
interesting let me just get drunk and
see what happens I don't have to like
get imaginative but it is issue in the
culture I agree we talked about this
like a lot not so much recently I feel
like we used to talk about it more like
how alcohol Centric like our culture is
and like binge drinking not just like
having a glass of wine like everything
is just extreme extreme with the
drinking and I don't think it was always
like this yeah no it's definitely
um it's just like a part of life now
like postgrad life but I don't think
it's a good I think it's something that
needs to be like addressed in some way
because I I think it contributes to a
lot of issues like mental health heal it
doesn't help mental health it doesn't
help physical health like mhm no it's
true it's a it's a wider issue and a
wider conversation and this is just one
yeah so I was saying like I don't think
that like this is a a Bravo specific
issue you know getting that drunk but
obviously doing it on camera makes your
life way harder yeah but also like
having producers like encourage you to
drink and then not address when you are
sick the next day and make you go and
film and then you're throwing up like
that's not like a good working
environment yeah I also I didn't watch
ultimate girls trip but in the Vanity
Fair article leam mqueen talks
extensively about her she was basically
told like they're putting together
Rooney Legacy at this point um and so
doing ultimate girls trip will be really
good for you if you want to get on
Legacy and at this point she's like back
in her sobriety and she's like
unwavering and she gets just kind of
like made fun of and like put down for
being boring and like Andy had all the
women on from that particular season on
watch happen's live and was like was
Leah boring um and they just kind of
like mock her about it yeah it's not the
right environment if you're trying to
like live
a a a boring life really I do like I I
think hearing from Leah and Ebony and
their like firsthand experience
was powerful I I I am skeptical of
Bethany's motives in this because she's
just I can't read her I feel like up
until recently like she was still riding
the house like her rewatch podcast like
she was still riding so hard she was
like so close with Andy she goes on on
watch rein live like she still uses the
platform I'm I'm confused about her uh
intentions honestly yeah and I would
like to know from other
Housewives from other cities like I feel
like not everything is as Viti volatile
as New York was in it's like last season
in the last couple of years it was
really bad yeah you're right like
because because honestly one of the
takeaways from my article and again I
haven't finished it but was that it
feels like a very Roney problem yeah but
then they were talking about like
Anonymous Housewives and then I was that
felt to me like someone from Beverly
Hills but like no maybe it was just
another person and if it was a roony
problem then this article should be like
what happened to the real house eyes of
New York maybe the further down we get
like it'll go into a new franchise just
like we're starting with Rony and here
is like Bethany Leah Ebony and then like
maybe it goes into a new city yeah maybe
not
though I'll keep scrolling and and we
apologize for not having finished this
oh and then there's
um Brandy Glenville you're right
Brandy Glenville
speaks Caroline Mano oh with Brandy
Glenville right and then they obviously
talk about pump rules and The Bachelor
and just like the love is blind guy like
just the uh General State of the Union
on reality
TV got it okay well we'll finish reading
it we'll let you know tomorrow if
there's anything really more but you
know not the best look for Bravo I don't
think it's really going to like change
much me neither I think that I could
have guessed a lot of this it's not you
know you don't go to the network for
moral uh like we know what you're
watching yeah and in the beginning of
the article they say like this is the
price that you pay for what you get in
return for some women it's a million
dollars a season okay so you're going to
wake up in your own urine and you're
going to embarrass yourself and you're
going to over drink but like that might
be worth it to you for that Pati you
right or for that Fame yeah because a
lot of the women who go on
don't do it for the money they're set
financially it's a show about affluent
women not really roony anymore but like
the Rony women were doing it for money
but for a lot of the other women it's
just about popularity and fame yeah
which when you go into something with
that goal nine times out of 10 it's not
going to work out for you like it's when
those are your
uh desires it's it's [__] yeah but
they were saying like after Bravo KH one
year one like Anonymous housewife was
like how will I ever be happier than
this like that level of that's what
they're there for that's what they're
there for right so everything has a
price yeah Bravo is definitely just like
a really interesting social experiment
for sure and I wouldn't say it's like a
non-toxic environment no I wouldn't
either so but I wouldn't have said that
before either right I I didn't learn
really anything new from this article
yeah but when tea is hot I'll be sipping
it agreed agreed are you ready for our
next story yes Travis Barker is slamming
the ridiculous rumor that his fling with
Kim caused his the feud with Courtney
you know what I'm glad yeah honestly the
fact that he's addressing it on his head
makes me feel like that's not the reason
but um yeah it was a crazy time
nonetheless so he um did an extensive
interview with the LA Times on Sunday
and he finally addressed the ridiculous
speculation that began circulating when
excerpts from his book resurfaced
earlier this year he said quote you give
people a little information and they
think they've solved the this mystery of
this is why they're fighting it's just
so ridiculous UL it's like Courtney's
fans are worried about Travis he's a
womanizer stop it he added in his book
he called Kim [__] hot and admitted
to secretly checking her out while he
dated Kim while he dated Paris he said I
obviously shared all that stuff because
I wanted to move past it it was
therapeutic for me he further insisted
there was no drama within the Kardashian
family over his short-lived crush on Kim
he said that's her sister she knows we
used to talk nothing bad was going on no
I'm sorry like it's so weird it's weird
like as someone with sisters oh my God I
could never okay no think about like
someone who I used to talk to 10 years
ago maybe even more no I can't you can't
and say like snitch wound up marrying
them not that weird it's
weird it's weird and I guess maybe
that's not weird but what's weird is
that if that guy wrote a book and told
people like and then I would die yeah
yeah but he wrote it like before he got
with Courtney so he was just like
sharing no I know it's I'm sorry like
it's undeniably odd it's just odd but do
you believe him that that's not the
source of the
rift I do I I don't think it's as simple
as that and we've seen tension gr
between Courtney and Kim for years
agreed agreed but I will say I loved
Courtney's Halloween costume Perfection
Perfection culturally relevant on theme
you know pregnant is yeah it's hard to
be pregnant into a costume yeah loved
loved loved and it also just kind of for
me at least buries this fight that
they've been having cuz they're
obviously cool if she's doing that like
himim had to lend her the dress it was
the exact dress I think so that's so
funny perfect costume yeah love perfect
pregnant costume and the fact that it
ended up you know perfect pregnant
costume for any pregnant person but the
fact that came is her sister makes it
even better and she looks like her so
they looked identical I loved it yeah
any other good costumes that you want to
share
like no
yeah what about you no I didn't see that
much like everybody just kind of like
gave up this year and I'm so here for it
yeah agreed are you ready for our next
story what number four oh my God no oh
my gosh got to get ready four is brought
to you by hatch
restore as we get older our
responsibilities and challenges increase
causing level stress levels to rise
prioritizing quality sleep is is one of
the best ways to take care of yourself
instead of lingering on your phone
before bed make sleep your simplest
self-care routine with the hatch restore
too you guys know I'm in my low-lift
Wellness era I want to do Wellness
things but I'm not like meditating and
going on Hikes so I asked people I'm
like what are good low lift Wellness
things that I can do and everyone said
the hatch let me tell you my mornings
are so different I love the unwind
before bed stuff with hatch but I really
love how they wake you up with the
sounds and the light it's so civilized
civilized Jackie add it to the list of
things you told me to get and then I
finally did so the hatch restore 2 is
your bedside sleep guide it's your ally
in rest the Innovative all-in-one dream
machine is a sophisticated sound machine
light and alarm clock that's beautifully
designed for your bedside table good
rest allows you to be the best version
of yourself which is why the hatch
restore 2 was engineered to help you
form healthy sleep habits for Life your
hatch teaches your body when it's time
to go to sleep when it's time to rise
with light and sound cues it coaches you
through meditations and mindful
exercises that transform the time before
an after sleep I can't lie I don't do
the the meditations but if that's for
you love that I love the lights Ben
loves I never heard of pink noise before
pink noise Brown noise Ben Ben loves the
pink noise we we sleep at full volume
every night so right now hatch is
offering our listeners $20 off your
purchase of a hatch restore 2 and free
shipping at hatch. toast sleep deeply
and wake gently with the restore 2 go to
hatch. toast to get $20 off and free
shipping that's hatch. co/ toast today's
episode is also brought to you by the
Skylight frame is there someone in your
life who's hard to give a gift to a
spouse friend sister mom Grandma Etc
will check out the Skylight frame the
Skylight frame is everything you need
it's a touchscreen digital digital
picture frame that allows you to send
photos straight to your phone and they
appear in seconds it's holiday season
like for so many people on your list the
Skylight frame is the best and only
option it's the perfect gift for a
grandparent new parents a spouse you can
effortlessly send photos from the photo
from your phone to the frame with the
free Skylight app or the unique email
it's so easy to use even if you're not
Tech friendly or you know you're sending
it to your grandma who's not Tech
friendly it could setup takes less than
60 seconds and the touchscreen is so
beautiful it's also a game changer you
can swipe through the photos tap to see
new photos sent there's even like a
little like button it looks beautiful in
your home they have new color options
that match any style so it comes in
black white silver and a limited edition
poppy which is an orangey red and of
course it also comes in Gold comes in
two sizes the 10-in or the 15in gallery
frame it's better than social media it
has thoughtful features like using the
app displaying photos without Wi-Fi
satisfaction guaranteed they're
confident that you'll love Skylight that
they're offering a free 120-day return
so over a million happy customers
thousands of festar reviews and as a
special limited time offer for our
listeners get $15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com
toast that'll get $15 off your purchase
of a skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com toast that's Sky l i g
HT f r m.com toast thank you
Claud next story Leonardo DiCaprio's new
girlfriend Victoria chetti grabs his
butt in a not safe for work moment at a
Halloween party so the 25-year-old model
was all smiles and the steamy pictures
as she slid her hand into Leo's
underwear to cop a feel at a bash in LA
on Saturday night um she was dressed in
a bright red wig and he seemed to be
dressed as himself for the party um it's
just crazy that we have a picture of
this yeah so you're saying Leonardo
DiCaprio likes butt stuff and
honestly this is gross this is gross now
of course like it's an intimate moment
and it's not like they were out in
public like being gross like this is a
moment that shouldn't have been photogra
private moment right um so like I do
feel bad that like this is like this
shouldn't have been shared it's like
rude it's like did she then go put her
hand in chips
Bowl not the mix nuts you're so right I
hope she washed her
hands but but also like was it just
cheek it looks to be in the center like
no yeah like it's but her it's like her
wrist I would say just her hand is in
like her wrist starts to it's not like
all the way deep in okay wait I have but
it is centered so it's like it's giving
crack I was just going to say it's
giving crack I'm now like studying it
also looks like in one of the photos
she's kind of making eye contact with
the paparazzi no she look up into to the
right a little bit and I don't think
it's Paparazzi like I I feel like
this is like someone's cell phone
because this is like a back patio of a
house this is a private moment for sure
yeah I also like don't even know this
girl who is she she's an Italian runway
model okay I mean now that I'm looking
at the hand placement it's 100% giv
crack which I guess is better than hole
but not better than cheek agree it goes
It Go
cheek crack hole by way that's the title
today cheek crack
hole cheat crack hole I feel bad that we
like know about this photo and that
we're but we have to you know do our
jobs and analyze it but we were not
meant to see this and like people are
should be entitled to a private moment
but it's also like you know they're at a
party and they are big stars and people
watch what you do I just want to say
like crack is bad like crack is w
cheek is like really it's innocent like
cheek is is skin you know there's a lot
of action at the crack especially man
they have hairy cracks they have like
dingleberries and stuff crack is
gross Yeah the more I think about it I
just want to know if she then hit up the
chips and dip yeah it's a question good
thing about Hollywood parties they
really don't have snacks that's true but
like I don't know even if she touched
the door knob like I know like now we
have to go around thinking like going to
restaurants and stuff like did somebody
touch a crack and then put their hand on
the store but you already should be
thinking of that and there are other
things people could touch their own
crack they don't wash their hands like
just wash your hands you
know use just wash your hands that's
kind of like the message it always is it
always has been and always will be you
tell him says so I'm glad that he's
found love with an age appropriate girl
for him kind of no no no not like in his
C in like he's literally a joke like
she's 25 yeah he's literally a joke like
if I were him I wouldn't date someone
under 25 just so I wouldn't keep getting
joked about
yeah yeah CU once he dates someone who's
26 like the jokes themselves no and it's
like then you can break that myth myth
busting right but it's like she's legit
25 model yeah
model so not creative
no so anyways wash your hands everyone
wash your hands are you ready for our
fifth and final story I I don't know am
I you're giving me sort of like a
Sinister look it's a lot like there's a
lot to unpack um okay but it's like kind
of crazy what's going on with the Snow
White
movie Obsessed so you know this isn't a
snow white who's gonna get saved by a
prince that interview Rachel zler it's
giving Emma Watson she's getting dragged
like she is okay well snow uh Disney is
delaying their release of the live
action Snow White reboot which they've
already spent 330 million
on they're delaying it by a year and
dumping the diverse dwarfs after star
Rachel zler sparked Fury with a woke
rant against the 1937 original so
there's a wait there's two things going
on here two things this this movie is
mired in controversy one because of
Rachel's ug's recent comments two
because of what's going on with the
dwarfs which is actually maybe crazier
yeah I I agree so over the summer the
film received negative attention after
it was revealed by Daily Mail that the
Seven Dwarfs which who were iconic roles
in the original film were to be replaced
by seven magical non-dwarf creatures in
an effort to keep the storytelling in
line with 21st Century's commitment to
political correct political correctness
they were seen there was a picture that
was leaked on set of the movie and it
included a mix of men and women of
different ethnicities with one real
dwarf among their number at First Disney
denied these pictures were from the set
of the movie but eventually they
backtracked but now in a new publicity
shot for the movie Rachel zler is seated
and surrounded by seven CGI Dwarfs with
the diverse Originals nowhere to be seen
so it's like not only are they putting
these diverse original actors out of
work but also they're putting dwarfs
like at working acting dwarfs and also
the way Disney is doing everything not
to give work to the actor dwarf
Community First of all they should have
been cast originally like do you know
how few [__] roles there are right
for a for actor who is also a dwarf like
they wait a lifetime for a role like
this two then they finally use dwarves
and they're CGI right but that's
probably because of the SAG strike by
the way no I don't think so I think
they're trying to like blame it on the
strike as to why the movie will be
delayed but no cuz these promotional
pictures they would have been shot like
months ago they're just like coming out
now but I think also the issue because I
remember like Peter Dinklage was on a
podcast talking about like Snow White
and how they he was very against using
dwarfs he was just against the I I feel
like he was against
the premise the the film's premise
itself and their use of dwarfs in the
movie but it's like if you're going to
make the movie and you're just going to
like recast the dwarfs I don't think
that's helpful I think his issue is like
either don't make the movie it's it's a
problematic movie then it's problematic
period right right and they were like
you know trying to correct all these
other things about the movie and he's
like this core thing is the problem
right also is the word
dwarf
offensive I don't think so I think
little person and dwarfism are okay
obviously no one's allow like you never
use the MW okay okay but I yeah no I
think so cuz maybe like changing the
name but still giving like the actors
the opportunity actually I think you're
on to something I think the correct term
is little person and the medical like
diagnosis
is dwarfism but I actually don't know if
you should say like dwarf right so maybe
there could be like a different I don't
know what the solution is but neither
does Disney and these two solutions are
terrible to just keep the concept but
not employ the actors yeah no that's the
thing and I'm sure as a if you're a
little person whose dream is to be an
actor there are so [__] few
opportunities for you know there's only
one uh what's his
name what's Peter dinklage's character
in Game of there's only one Tyrion
Lannister okay there's not a million
opportunities like that and I'm sure uh
Peter Dinklage is he's really like the
the face of his community yeah
and that sucks that there's no roles for
for an actor who's a little person like
that sucks yeah and now they're going to
be replaced by CGI when it's like isn't
that what the whole strike is about like
please don't replace us yeah and then
there's the other part that I had seen
on Tik Tok where Rachel zler and you
know I love her
galot are being cringe like they're you
know bringing their
their woman First Energy to this kind of
antiquated role I think we all just
really kind of need to accept that like
the Disney movies are old school and
that's okay you know and it's like
either don't remake them or make them
with people who can accept that and just
or make new ones like Moana like she's a
female character she's a leader she's a
warrior
she's leading her community Frozen she's
power right the power of Sisterhood so
to try and redo movies
that we people find problematic I just
don't think you're ever going to win
like cuz people like them and to cast
them with people who find them
problematic like I'm sure there are
people who are like yeah I'll be Snow
White I don't care so there's like this
interview of Rachel zler and Gaga do
being asked about it on a red carpet and
like it's just giving like cringe like
Rachel zler like this no white like
she's not going to be waiting for a
prince she literally waiting for a
prince she's literally dead until a man
kisses her like that's the movie that's
the movie that's the premise of the
movie so me like don't do it don't
seriously don't don't revamp it don't do
the role like yeah don't do the don't do
sign onto a movie that you hate like
right and you have to like do press
requisite for when you or ask questions
about it like you need a a disclaimer a
million girls would kill for that role
for that role to be saved by the prince
yeah they wouldn't say they would say
Snow White is a great gal I also feel
like Rachel zegler is just like having
like a slew of bad press in like recent
years she almost like can't get out of
her own way first with that Oscars thing
yeah and I just feel like she's made
herself like kind of unlikable yeah and
she like hates that video of herself
that made her viral which CU she's like
refuses to like let people acknowledge
that that made her famous she's like no
I was booked for a movie before like I
believe it the only reason I know her
Rachel like glorious is because of that
video and it's an amazing video yeah and
she's like doing a lot but I've never
seen her in anything she was in Westside
Story which was just buried yeah there a
lot of controversy anel yeah um then
there was the Oscar thing so I wonder if
it was good Westside
Story sure step Spielberg I feel like it
wasn't good because if it was was good
the cream Rises and people would be like
it's good it's good yeah you're right
you're right it was probably atrocious
sound off in the comments that's on
Steven Spielberg did you yeah that's
like that tracks did you watch Westside
Story is it good should we add it to our
holiday movie list I don't think so
people let us know yeah I but the thing
is with Rachel zler she's enormously
talented like singing wise and she's a
very talented skilled artist yeah but I
think a lot of her public Persona Mars
that you know people have a hard time
seeing past that because things like
this go viral and it's just it's a
little like out of touch yeah and cringe
yeah but she thinks that this is what
people like want to hear right she's
slaying it's a slay girl bossing so
close to the Sun girl boss town but it's
a little too close yeah it's true yeah
and like these are Classics like just
leave them let them I know like can we
can we just all have an understanding
like yeah the classics deeply
problematic but like we could still
enjoy them yeah with the understanding
of like things have changed of course
yeah no but like even Beauty and the
Beast like if you look if you read too
much into it she fell in love with her
cap like she literally was ready to like
[__] a beast um yeah nobody even talks
about like the beastiality she didn't
even know he was like a lowkey prince
yeah she was ready to she was down to
clown that's why you just can't think
about it too much just enjoy it for what
it is that's the whole premise of being
entertained it's a suspense of disbelief
you know we know in real life you just
have to like forget it forget
it I've been waiting for a true love's
kiss is that Snow White Snow White is
one of the Disney movies Enchanted Snow
White is one of the Disney movies I'm
like honestly I'm familiar with what
songs are from Snow
White let's look at good call that is a
good call I think there's one where
they're like marching her and the
dwarves Snow White and now it's like
conflated with Snow White and the
Huntsman so they tried to do right they
did it
twice with so work that's
like I don't know
it what else there's there's a ton but
not Someday My Prince Will Come I don't
think I know that one either
like maybe I just subconsciously
distanced myself from Snow White because
I knew it was problematic hi ho hi ho
that's is off the work go that's a good
one that was the marching song I was
thinking of got
it
great there's others but I don't know
them they're not like hi ho honestly I
would just really like to hear from like
an actor who who is a little person like
what are your thoughts on this agreed
and of course like everybody goes to
Peter Dinklage cuz he's like the most
famous one but I I wanted like
struggling actors people who are up and
coming you know it's easy for Peter
Dinklage almost but also not even um
actors just the little people in general
like what do you think about this yeah
yeah yeah that's true I I I defer to
them yeah sound off in the comments I'm
very
curious yeah
we'll we'll keep you posted this is
going to be a yearl long Saga yeah it's
it's
murky
yeah but at least we have Snow White and
the Hunts Spin and Mirror Mirror which
came out at the same time right on Q
yeah and honestly at least we have
Beauty and the Beast and we have great
songs from Snow White and the Huntsman
those um Florence in the machine oh
you're
right they went so hard on that movie
they did fired on all cylinders I feel
like it wasn't appreciated in its time I
don't even think it did well and that
was because there was another Snow White
movie live action that literally came
out at the same time Mir Mir but they
were so different but like that remains
one of the Mysteries why did the both of
those movies get made at the exact same
time like why couldn't one just be sheld
for like five years and we could have
enjoyed both and had them spaced out and
then we would have this one coming up
too
right like everyone was all hot for Snow
White now they can't even figure out how
to do it it's weird it's so true I do
think on the scale of like all the
different old school classic Disney
films Snow White is probably one of the
more um murky ones you know because it's
the you know it's the concept of what's
called and she's sleeping she's sleeping
it's not consensual kiss right right
that one's probably the one that has the
most issues that's probably the one I
wouldn't remake right but like
Cinderella cute cute right problematic
they remade it and I think it went off
well which one are you talking about
camil Cabo Richard Madden no the Camila
Cabo yeah I guess they did remake it
again that I feel like it was like a
nonassociated that has like a soundtrack
that was like a it was giving Janis
jober you know from 30 Rock like they
didn't have the license because they
they didn't even have like actual
Cinderella music in that Cil Cabo ad
Manzel one they used like Nickelback
songs like they used regular pop music
yeah yeah it was right you're talking
about Lily James Lily James and Richard
Madden that was like live action
Cinderella which I've seen bits of it's
like so good but I don't know that story
just like doesn't resonate with me me
neither but Cinderella isn't problematic
and I will say the best Cinderella
rendition is of course Whitney Houston
oh oh yeah but also then we also got
like a Cinderella Story Another
Cinderella Story and one more Cinderella
Story yeah true run it back Cinderella
story so Cinderella I think is like a
safe one Beauty and the Beast like it
has like a couple flare ups but it's
really not the thing is it's too good to
deny if it wasn't as good like people
would stop like trying to make fet
happen with it but it's like it's so
good that we all can turn a blind eye I
don't think the little mermaid is
problematic she's like a woman fighting
for her voice right yeah and she was
just remade and and it was good it was
good it was really good people love it I
haven't seen it but I've heard such good
things what other ones Aladdin is you
know I think they they have some issues
with Aladdin no because a bunch of the
characters are like thieves oh I don't
know I just I think they made a Reese in
Aladdin they like made a live action but
I don't think it was good was the
problem no and I actually heard a really
interesting story about that that lead
character whose name I don't know he
wasn't relatively famous and he was
basically saying like I was in the
biggest movie of the year like at the
time and I have not been able to get a
single job out like have you the guy who
played Aladdin could did you tell me his
name no no he got like no success after
that it was really interesting
interesting yeah he thought it would
like change his life big break the
beginning of something and it was just
like this one movie yeah kind of like
Nikki blansky kind of like the guy who
played opposite Brandy in Cinderella yes
he was a cutie and he went nowhere
nowhere yeah I wonder why and then I
feel like there are a lot of movies that
haven't been remade I don't know if they
will The Lion King was remade I don't
think the Lion King is Li King was
Perfection that most recent Recreation
like actually brought me to tears it's
so good it's it's on par with Beauty and
the Beast live action like I watch one
of the most beautiful things oh my God
it's amazing that opening scene the
opening it's so it's perfect with the
drums oh my God chilling yeah if you
haven't watched that one you got to
watch it yeah I what other ones have
been recreated like
recently I don't
know do you think the do like live
action
Frozen live action Moana because those
are like newer I guess and they're not
Disney are they yeah they are Pixar
Pixar's Disney right I don't know Disney
Pixar I don't know I think it is it is
it is it is
okay so
interesting there you go there you go
that's a story that is developing
developing and we'll keep you posted and
that was our show those were the Fast
Five gorgeous to be back with you all
this week you as well and I hope you
guys have a great day thank you so much
for listening to the toast tomorrow's
our Halloween
episode oh sorry tomorrow's our
Halloween episode so that's a big one
and I'm really excited me too I've to
get into
character thank you guys so much for
listening to the T L Morning Show where
we deliver the fast five stories you
need every M Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast anywhere podcast can be found
so Spotify iTunes s public radio iard
radio cast box all the places where you
listen to podcast find us toast leave
five star VI but a beautiful standing
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing Trey fabulous day
and we'll see you tomorrow for toast to
we 202
bye love you
bye